we charge genocide is this
intergenerational grassroots effort that
really seeks to Center the voices and
experiences of young people of color who
are most targeted by police violence
every time they see a cop they feel fear
right that like that that's something
that is just a problem of the whole CPD
it's in the past six months 27 people
have been shot by CPD and 23 of them are
black I see what's going with our youths
our children what they're going through
every day it's something that like I
think we cannot stand for it I think
that it's up to us as a community to be
the ones to really lead this effort we
need more people connecting to this
movement right we have the organizations
we have the campaigns we just need more
people getting involved we're standing
up in New York one more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your app store
now